welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright today is day 4
and we're gonna figure out how to find
your purpose I think you should chase
what energizes you everyone talks about
passion legacy purpose yeah the one word
to pay attention to his energy I love
that that's it let's simplify this okay
so whatever energizes you naturally
expands you feels like possibility is
exciting to do it may be scary that
doesn't matter
it has to do with how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good it expanded you it
energized you chasing the money that was
the game that was your passion that was
your per there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are well yeah because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what
happened and and the reason why I say
that is because people talk about the
word passion
yeah or purpose right and the truth is
it's not a person place or a thing it's
not it is the feeling
of being expanded and energized right if
you're pursuing your passion it means
that you wake up every day and our
energized so instead of trying to think
what's my purpose what's my passion was
my purpose what's my passion Canoga yeah
instead of thinking like that I want you
instead to ask yourself what's what
could I do today that would energize me
what energizes me if it's making money
figure out how to make money if it is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah nothing more exhilarating
but what happens is once you learn how
to do something once you can do it over
and over again and so it starts to
become routine yeah which means it's no
longer energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit the money that you need
to make then you're like I'm not the
hell yeah do that finally you know I did
that yes
yeah and it's because you were energized
by the money and now you're not yeah now
you've got to be energized by the next
thing I'm wondering what would be the
single most valuable piece of advice you
give us to even attempt to create some
of the value that you guys have done in
both your very impressive companies
people say you you have to have a lot of
passion for what you're doing and it's
totally true and the reason is is
because it's so hard that if you don't
any rational person would give up it's
really hard and you have to do it over a
sustained period of time so if you don't
love it if you're not having fun doing
it you don't really love it you're gonna
give up and that's what happens to most
people actually if you really look at
that the ones that ended up you know
being successful unquote the eyes of
society and the ones that didn't
oftentimes it's the ones that are
successful love what they did so they
could persevere well you know when it
got really tough and and the ones that
didn't love it quit because they're
saying right who would want to put up
with this stuff if you don't love it so
it's a lot of hard work and and it's a
lot of worrying constantly and if you
don't love it you're gonna fail so you
got to love it you got to have
ever since I was five years old that's
when Neil Armstrong stepped onto the
surface of the Moon I've been kind of
passionate about space rockets rocket
engines space travel I became a science
fiction reader and I've always known
that I wanted to you know do something
having to do with space and I've spent a
lot of time thinking about it for really
almost my whole life and that's one of
the things you guys will find that you
have passions and having a passion is a
gift I think we all have passions and
you don't get to choose them they pick
you but you have to be alert to them you
have to be looking for them and when you
find your passion it's a fantastic gift
for you because it gives you direction
it gives you purpose you could have a
job or you can have a career or you can
have a calling and the best thing is to
have a calling and if you find your
passion you'll have that and all your
work won't feel like work to you passion
is not an actionable word it's correct
you know that those who do the things
that they're passionate about do better
but it's not helpful advice and so the
question is where does passion come from
passion is a result passion as an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know and I think
we mistake that passion is something we
do in our private lives but it shouldn't
be done you know in our careers for
example and I'm a firm believer that you
are who you are and anybody who says I'm
different at home than I am at work in
one of those two places you're lying and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home and it works something that you
have excitement to do so how do you find
the things that you're excited to do
well it's actually easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling and and be pay for it so
what are the things that I do in the
weekend right I love I'm very involved
in the art world I love to go to museums
and galleries but I love to go see dance
and performances because I want to see
how others are
or interpreting the world so that
inspires me new ideas new thoughts new
ways of looking at the world are things
that interest me privately and I seek it
out and pay money for it right so does
that mean I have to have a career in the
arts no it means I have to have a career
where new ideas are explored where
people are experimenting and trying
things out and I have to explore new
ideas and try things out and I'm just as
excited to go to work everyday as I am
just you know go do something on a
Saturday night and so the idea of
finding your passion is ironically
simple because you should be doing stuff
that you enjoy sometimes what is the
stuff that you enjoy and then what is
the stuff that you love who the people
you love and what others were they all
have in common when I was small mom I
was also really under sized so it's
probably the reason I lift weights I was
always there every baseball picture I'm
the kid holding a sign in the front
right so I was small and skinny they
used to tease me Eddie spaghetti you
know and I'd get bullied at school and I
never retaliated so I had that mix with
shyness mixed with chaos in my home
which many people can relate to and I
got to tell you the the shift for me
sports was good for me because it gave
me an Al that I finally found something
that I was pretty good at I think the
biggest shift in our lives the things
that makes us the happiest is that when
somebody helps us identify our natural
giftedness and when I was a little boy
when I got a little bit older they
pointed out my speed so wasn't my lack
of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business they said you know you're
intense when someone points out a gift
about you that you also kind of
intuitively know to be true they're
linked to them if you're intense your
passion you won't get out work you're
relentless I want I am those things and
when someone linked those gifts to me
winning now I believed I could win
that's the other way to change identity
is when someone can link your giftedness
to the victory you'll believe it not
like you're great that's general that's
bull but it's something you know
specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag them there's a few
things you know you know what I am good
at these things right I've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer
this general you-you-you don't need to
be the smartest person in the room
because you probably are most of the
time so there's a confidence know
there's a confidence that allows you to
be present when you interview me and
just listen that's different than anyone
who's interviewed me before and so
that's a natural giftedness for you
which is why there's a part of you that
kind of knows I am pretty you wouldn't
say if I am pretty good at this this is
a good program and so the way we change
our identity the way I changed mine was
by getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was I suck I'm shy
I'm small I have a screwed-up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the way it is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
than at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction
here's how you develop a passion it
starts as a minor area of interest you
gain areas of interest by encountering a
lot of stuff so if you have encountered
a lot of things in your life go out
there and encounter stuff go sailing go
take a dance class go study neuroscience
like whatever it is just encounter a
whole bunch of very broad diverse things
from that you're gonna get sparks of
interest like oh I actually found that
interesting I want to learn more dive
deep through engagement not through
pondering through engagement you're
going to realize whether something is
gonna turn into an area of fascination
so as you go deeper into it you're gonna
either become fascinated or you're not
if you're not fascinated move on if you
are fascinated then that's an area where
you're gonna ask yourself one very
simple question do I want to become the
best in the world at that thing if you
do if you want to become truly
extraordinary in that thing then go down
the path of gaining mastery now the
reason I think that it's wise to ask
that question going in is when you frame
it up I'm gonna become the best in the
world with this immediately people
understand the amount of time energy and
weight that it would take to become
truly great at that thing and I don't
think that passion can happen unless
you're becoming truly great at that
thing that's part of passion I don't
think people are deeply passionate about
something that they really suck at and
I'll give you an example I love video
games I absolutely love playing
first-person shooters I
learn a lot from them I get a lot out of
them I really just intrinsically enjoy
the time it has both that sense of
eating a cake because it's just fun in
the moment and it I pull from it life
lessons business lessons I practice
getting out of the sympathetic nervous
system into the parasympathetic nervous
system it's literally gamified so I'm
getting better I have points I can you
know have my improvement turned into
metrics it's all of it I really really
enjoy but I won't say that I'm deeply
passionate about it I'm just not that
good at it so it's one of those things
if I really wanted to develop a deep
passion for video video games and put it
at the center of my life that then I
would set down that path of really
practicing now this is like this is the
most important thing that passion will
do for you which is it's gonna pull you
through boredom it's gonna pull you
through the hard times and that's why
it's really got to be something that you
just are prepared to become great at
because when you're prepared to become
great there's just these insane moments
of boredom repetition and all of that
and if you have this burgeoning passion
coming out of that that's what's gonna
give you the energy to get through it so
it's this symbiotic relationship between
a developing passion and how hard it is
to actually really get great at
something so the things you get great at
need to be something that is this
developing passion so there you have it
that's how you do it and then that's why
you do it you write in the book there is
no faith and no courage and no sacrifice
in doing what is expedient what do you
say to those viewers that don't pursue
their dreams and are locked into their
careers because they are too afraid to
take risks and pursue something
meaningful well the first thing I would
say is well you should be afraid of
taking risks and pursuing something
meaningful but you should be more afraid
of staying where you are if it's making
you miserable it's like the first thing
you want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any any permanent
security outside of your ability to
contend and adapt it's the same issue
with children it's like you're paying a
price by sitting there being miserable
and you might say well the devil I know
is better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking yeah and if you're miserable in
your job now and you change nothing in
five years you'll be much more miserable
and you'll be a lot older
but they sends it the luxury to pursue
what is meaningful our viewers have
mortgages they have children yeah they
have payments and loans it's a luxury to
pursue because we like the resources
well I don't think I don't remember now
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy it's a luxury to pursue what makes
you happy it's a moral obligation to
pursue what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
to let's say you have family and and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities you've already picked
up those responsibilities you don't just
get to walk away scot-free it's a well I
don't like my job I quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do I
have to do about that
well I have to look for another job well
no one wants to hire me it's like okay
maybe you need to educate yourself more
maybe you need to update your your
curriculum vitae your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like you you have to
think about these things strategically
if you're going to switch careers you
have to do it like an intelligent
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of effort to do properly
I've dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for
happiness it's a moral responsibility to
push you what is meaning absolutely I
just can't explain to everybody like
clear when you figure out who you are
and do all that you win if you're great
a painting paint and hire a partner to
be your salesperson if somebody at 20
years old made me their business partner
as a painter maybe the most famous
painter in the world yet most painters
want to be the salesmen and business men
and women as well as the painter and
there's a problem
85% of painting 90 percent of people
that are great a painting are artists
and don't have the
to sell and vice versa all my sales
friends and business friends that want
to start all these businesses around
something creative I've got news for you
Joel you know you can be a great
salesman but your pottery sucks and so
that's that so like and it's that's a
very funny analogy for the following
figure out who you are don't apologize
for who you are and then become even
greater than you naturally are at what
you are well that's the whole the whole
the whole games broken because
everybody's too tied up into other
people's opinions I only care about my
opinion myself and I care what my mom
and wife and kids and the world think
just not as much as I care about the way
I think about myself and I and that's it
just that slight advantage and I think
most of you care more about what other
people think than what you think about
yourself and or you actually don't feel
good about yourself right the thing that
made me smile when you just introduced
me you said I'm one of the most
motivational people in the world , and
everybody I know that's medam said he's
the nicest guy there's no comparison to
the better feeling of people that have
actually gotten to know me say that
versus millions hundreds of thousands
tens of thousands thinking I'm the
coolest and and and that's it I mean
that's it and that's why it's and that's
why it's easy for me to feel good about
myself right and so I think a lot of
people need to start with themselves
maybe the reason they don't have more
confidence in themselves or care about
their opinion about themselves versus
others is because they know they're
doing things they don't like so they
need to work on that I get offered and
emailed 5,000 different requests for
podcasts and shows and what what I think
my friend here on let's see his name
Evan buh buh let's send it in buh
I'm sorry Evan Carmichael introduced me
to bow with bows figured out his time as
the asset and so if you want Kevin Hart
or the rock or
or Beyonce or ja rule or Richard Branson
or Tony Shane or Sheryl Sandberg
on your podcast maybe you should start
the hundred twenty second podcast and
then you gotta be creative and try to
figure out how you get maybe you create
the one question video show that's it no
shows one question promise you a lot of
people that you want as guests if they
see in the headline
I just need four minutes of your time
for the one question show a lot more
gonna say yes then can you be on my
podcast for an hour and a half a brain
tattoo I love sharing with my audiences
is this one
a job is only just a job if you see it
as a job and so why would you lose the
opportunity to leverage what you do
every day to grow your happiness to grow
your energy to allow you to release more
your talents in the world to allow you
to help more people why would you miss
that opportunity by falling into the
trap of thinking this is much as my job
I'm just getting up in the morning I'm
working 9:00 to 5:00 going down to the
coal mine every day and you could say
well Robin this doesn't apply to me you
know I just have a ordinary job well
I've got to tell you I've met taxi
drivers who feel their work is
incredibly meaningful I mean I was at
LaGuardia and I remember you know being
in a taxi cab and the man had this white
shirt and his tab was perfection and I
said you know your attitude is great
your passion is awesome your your cab is
perfect you've got this fresh newspaper
for me to read what is your psychology
that allows you to do this and he said
Robin this is not a dirty job it's an
important job I get to make a difference
I remember being Johannesburg meeting
the janitor in the Johannesburg men's
room or WC who worked like he was the
Elon Musk of what he did his he worked
like Pavarotti saying and so my point is
simply this it's really your choice as
to how you will
you the work you do every day and even
in the most quote-unquote ordinary work
you can find gold and if you connect
with the gold you connect with the
meaning and if you connect with the
meaning you connect with your talents
and if you connect with your talents you
connect with the best within you and if
you connect with the best within you you
go to work every day and you are this
shining star of world class and you
become the Picasso of your industry and
everything else takes care of itself
once you know your purpose your
direction is clear there will be no
confusion I'm gonna its Wow but there
were times in my life I didn't know
where I wanted to go I didn't know what
I wanted to do but you know why because
I didn't know my purpose I had no idea
what I was supposed to do I remember I
remember retiring from the NFL and I was
like you know I'm too good to go out
there and get any job but my purpose
wants to take care of my family but I
was sitting up on the college ah you
know what it's all gonna be good
it's not a problem I'm telling ya it's
shameful it was a shameful and I
remember us running out of money and I
have to dig in the couches and try to
find money for milk for my kids and I
was missing my purpose I was in
confusion one day my wife came to me she
the honey you need a job I'm like you
know what I can't just go out there and
do any job you know I was in the NFL you
know that and she said well you know
what I don't care that you were in the
NFL we need some milk we need to eat we
need gas what are you gonna do and my
first job I remember I was humbled solo
my first job in LA I went to a place
called Labor ready and I showed up at
5:00 in the morning and there were
ex-cons there were drug addicts there
were all kind of people there and they
would give you a job for the day for
eight hours and I remember making $8 an
hour for eight hours and they would send
me all over there so you got a car I was
like yeah I got one but you gonna go
over here and you're gonna work in this
factory and I
grabbing that broom picking it up and I
started sweeper and I remember feeling
lowered and low I was like man and again
here come the pity party I was in the
NFL I know I was running around with big
stars I was doing it making money doing
all this stuff and Here I am sweeping
the floor and it was horrible and I felt
miserable but then all of a sudden
something happened I was sweeping I
started to realize that I was doing
something about my situation that
instead of sitting around talking about
it instead of sitting around real
wondering where my opportunity was
telling as well
I was proactive and let me tell you
something I was fulfilling my purpose I
got the money for my family and I
realized that I am NOT going to just sit
ever again and that was the turning
point in my life in a major major way
once I found out what my purpose was
you'd do anything in your purpose and
you still stay there and you can be
you'll be 100% on the right path
once you transform yourself and even
though I'm still I'm not running from
myself I'm constantly facing myself I'm
constantly battling myself I'm not
running from them anymore I used to but
now I'm constantly battling them so now
what happens is once you get to port in
your life where you're able to be on a
podcast or be on a TV show and tell
everybody I'll step you are I will
answer any question you want about me
anything I did anything bad good ugly I
will tell you when you get to that point
in your life that's where your real
journey begins and you no longer have to
have a small victory to keep you going
you now realize what your purpose in
life is and you realize all this is just
part of it but at first you need all
these different tactics to keep you
going because you haven't figured it out
yet once you figure out that you're in a
race amongst billions of people that
live in this world you're in a race by
yourself you have a purpose and it's
your purpose now there bones the purpose
it is your purpose and only your purpose
and it's your race
so then you're like hey ma'am I'm doing
my thing
I'm doing the best of my ability what's
next there's no longer these small
increments to get through life because
once you figure out why you're here
it just becomes a process I have worked
all over the world I mean all over Asia
China South America and North America
Europe and I'm always asking people what
do you really want and I have found most
people don't want to be really wealthy
what they do want is they don't want to
have any financial concerns if they want
to bind their suit they can go and get
one if they want to take a trip they can
take the trip if they want a new car
they can get the new car they want to
just run out and spend or buy they don't
want to have any financial concerns -
they want to wake up in the morning
excited about how they're gonna spend
their day and the third they want to mix
with people who are upbeat and
creatively productive these are the
three things that people really want so
in answer to your question if somebody's
watching what's the first thing they
should do well the first thing they
should do is understand why we have
goals not just to set a goal because
most people don't set goals right they
they're operating with a limited level
of consciousness so they're thinking hmm
if I could get a little more money and
if I could get him to help me and her to
help me and this happened then I could
do this maybe this is get a new car what
we kind of understand is we're treating
our life for our goals literally trading
our life would you trade your life for a
car or a house I don't think so so it's
got to be something really meaningful
and we're not taught to think this
way we should sit down
and don't give any thought to where the
money is gonna come from where the help
is gonna come from it's what do you
really want Mike ed Hillary was a
beekeeper in Auckland that's right he
wanted to climb Mount Everest it had
never been done great people died trying
to do it he went in 51 and failed he
went back in 52 and failed in 1953 he
stood on top of the mountain with
Tenzing Norgay but he didn't know how to
get there until after he had got there
Edison didn't know how to illuminate the
world until after he had done it the
Wright brothers were bicycle mechanics
in Dayton Ohio no one believed he could
fly they've been trying it for years but
they saw it but they wanted to do it
they didn't know how and they couldn't
tell you until after they had done it
now the first flight only lasted 12
seconds and the naysayers said yeah but
they only were up there for 12 seconds
they said we not only got up there we
kept the damn thing up there for 12
seconds so when a person sets a goal
they've got to say look what I want if I
just let my mind roar I'll just wander
use my imagination how do I really want
to live that's what they should be doing
when we talk about living our quest and
I think that living my quest really if I
look at on a daily basis it's finding my
own voice it's finding your voice it's
finding the song that only you can sing
off-key or not it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk in your shoes today it won't look
like it looked 10 years ago living your
quest is what can I do with my life so
that my life becomes infectious to
someone else
living my quests looks like how do I
make my fingerprint matter so big that
it lives beyond my transition day living
your quest is how can I forgive the
perceiving Li unforgivable so I can love
the absolute lovable living your quest
is how do I give myself a thousand
second chances and every time I get to
999 press reset yeah yeah living my
quest is is not some ambiguous
untouchable experience living my quest
means going back and healing the little
girl in me so that the woman can be free
it's going back at embracing the little
boy in you so that the man can show up
and give himself permission to cry when
necessary living your quest is not
something that you can't touch it's not
something that requires a stage or
lights or cameras living your quest is
being completing content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is all
right living your quest is as simple as
it is complex living your quest is about
giving yourself permission say
permission on a daily basis to become
the next best version of yourself living
your quest is not holding yourself
hostage to old decisions not holding
yourself hostage to shame blame guilt
regret and anger living your quest is
about recognizing that everyday I can be
reborn to my possibility living your
quest is as internal and personal as it
is public living your quest is about
recognizing that you have brilliance in
you and not being willing to dim your
light one more day living your quest
means not being afraid of the genius in
you even though you have doubt living
your quest is recognizing that you get
to sing your song off tune that you can
get to live
perfection while you master imperfection
now I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
a video you have to do something so pull
out your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets and you want them for free
check out the link in the description
below question number one what is your
strong why number two what are your
gifts that you need to get more in touch
with and number three how will you be
more strategic with your actions and if
you are doing the best life 30 challenge
with me put a hashtag best live 30 down
the comments below so we can celebrate
with you finding your purpose guys it's
not that difficult it's not that
difficult that's one of the most common
questions that I get here's how you do
it you think about the time in your life
where you felt the most worthless think
about the time the lowest load that
you've ever experienced in your life
what was that moment your purpose now
where you will get the most fulfilled of
all time will be helping people who are
currently going through the thing that
you went through that's it think about
the most painful moments of your life
the thing that you would never want to
experience ever again think about the
thing you would never wish upon your
worst enemy definitely not your friends
your family your kids think about that
moment your greatest purpose your
greatest enjoyment your greatest
fulfillment in life will come from
helping people who are currently facing
that thing that you faced that is your
purpose for life it will never get old
helping those people will never get
tiring I love helping entrepreneurs why
why do I spend so much time helping
entrepreneurs why am i doing my tour why
am i posting three times a day on
YouTube
why are posted six times a day in
Instagram why do all this work helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an alternate myself because when
I was 19 and started my business and I
was struggling and I was failing and I
was making $300 a month and it was too
embarrassed to tell my friends that I
couldn't barely survive that was making
no money when I turned down these
high-paying jobs I was embarrassed I was
ashamed
I told my business partner once that I
quit I felt so bad about myself as a
human though once I made it
I built my business I sold it I had
success the greatest joy in life for me
comes from still helping those pure
startup entrepreneurs I love helping
people who've already made it get to the
next level I love helping somebody who
has a million revenue and help them get
to two and five and ten it's great but I
resonate so much more where the person
is just getting started
who's struggling who's afraid who's
putting in tons of work and not seeing
results and that will be my purpose for
life you can find your purpose the exact
same way and then have clarity for the
rest of your life and you don't have to
chase one thing and then another thing
and then another thing and now I'm in it
for money and I went for this you'll
have to do that here's where I really
agree with Mal on chasing energy I love
the idea of chasing energy within your
purpose so you found out your why right
that's your why the next step is you
figure out your how the how is how are
you going to fulfill it so it's great
that I love helping entrepreneurs
amazing how am I going to do that
there's a lot of different ways for me
to do it and that will change and that's
where I can chase energy so as an
example I started with my website I
started with my website I love the idea
of having a place for people to come to
and consume content and have I had a
hundred thousand plus pieces of content
on my website and then I started
experimenting with YouTube just as
something to test and play around with
and I love that even more and so
eventually I shut down my website I
closed my 8 people who are on that team
brought them all over to YouTube then
scaled my team to have 24 people who's
helping me with my YouTube business
because that was where my energy was
going the website could still work
there's lots of ways to win but my
energy was over here I love YouTube I
love making videos much more than
writing content recently in the past six
months I felt a lot of energy going to
my Instagram why did I pick up Instagram
why have I gone so hardcore on Instagram
because I went on and I did an Instagram
live session and I realized that when
you did Instagram live
you could bring people in
picture-in-picture that i could be
coaching and helping somebody from my
place in toronto to somebody here in
columbus where i'm at now or Chicago or
Zambia or anywhere in the world and I
can see them because when you get text
questions on a YouTube live
you can't go deep you can't get the
context you can't ask back and forth
because it's very rarely the question
somebody comes in at with the actual
question that's buried deep below the
thing they actually need to work on but
when you have them picture-in-picture
and i'm a visual learners for a love be
able to see people's reactions when I
can see them there I can help them a lot
more and that Instagram live alone is
the thing that got me to play a much
bigger game on Instagram in the past six
months have grown my account from 8,000
followers or soda a hundred thousand now
my energy is going there and so where
the energy goes right results will
follow but it's still within my purpose
of helping entrepreneurs and so you
don't have to stumble around through
life chasing one thing and then the next
and the next
when you have your clarity of purpose it
makes everything so much easier if you
want to join the best life 30 challenge
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos to dive deeper into
purpose check out the playlist right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there